les rapides de la Chine un secteur prisé
par de nombreux navigateurs et amateurs
de sport nautiques mais ce qu'ils ne
savent peut-être pas c'est que s'il
tombe en panne ou partent à la dérive
les pompiers de Montréal ont l'ordre de
ne pas aller les sauver s'il dépasse un
certain point en théorie on ne pourrait
pas aller secourir quelqu'un qui est
juste ici l'autre côté à quelques mètres
depuis le décès du pompier Pierre
Lacroix Benoît Martel veut dénoncer le
problème de ce que le service de
sécurité incendie de Montréal le Sim
appelle la zone d'exclusion il craint
que l'équipage qui accompagnait le
pompier Lacroix soit blâmé pour sa mort
parce que leur embarcation a franchi
cette zone pour tenter de sauver la vie
de plaisanciers la ligne est quelque
part ici est-ce que est-ce qu'on est
capable d'avoir la ligne mais non la
zone d'exclusion selon ce que nous avons
découvert en retrouvant un rapport
d'enquête interne du Sim couvre le
secteur le dangereux des rapides de la
Chine elle a été créée par le Sim sans
tambour ni trompette à la suite d'un
autre chavirment en 2010 pour les
plaisanciers seuls c'est affiche en
plein milieu du fleuve averti du danger
mais rien pour indiquer que les pompiers
n'iront pas vous sauver dans les rapides
et qu'il n'y a que la Garde côtière qui
peut s'y rendre les bateaux
aucune idée on ne sait pas ce qu'on peut
prendre pour acquis que parfois sont là
des fois ils sont pas ils se demandent
surtout pourquoi l'administration plante
encourage les citoyens à profiter du
fleuve dans les circonstances c'est soit
on améliore le service à population de
ce côté-là ou bien il y a des gens qui
doivent être avisés de dire n'allez pas
là parce qu'il y a pas personne qui va
aller vous chercher
selon nos informations la cness.t qui
doit présenter jeudi les conclusions de
son enquête sur le chavirment d'octobre
dernier recommandera de maintenir en
place la zone d'exclusion dans les
rapides de la Chine ici Julie Dufresne
Radio-Canada Montréal